what's going on guys this is Rob and you
read that title correctly all the
superheroes die so this is a story
called Days of Future Past doomsday and
this is designed to kind of explain
exactly how events transpired that led
to the original Days of Future Past
storyline for those you guys who don't
know about Days of Future Past It Was
Written in Uncanny X-Men 141 and 142 by
Chris Claremont and basically the
Sentinels took over North America and
eradicated pretty much all the
superheroes in existence those who
didn't die were just basically sent off
to internment camps awaiting their
executions so what ends up happening
here is this basically picks up in what
you and I could refer to is like year
zero which is effectively the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelly
now there is a differentiation between
how this story unfolds in the original
Days of Future Past which leads me to
believe this is an alternate reality and
the reason why I say that is that in the
original Days of Future Past it was
mystique and her Brotherhood of evil
mutants that killed Senator Robert Kelly
Professor Xavier and Mora MCT tager in
order to establish that mutants should
not be messed with and that's when
everything went sideways here it's just
Robert Kelly and in fact Charles Xavier
will show up over the course of the
story but within four years of Robert
Kelly's assassination William Striker is
sworn in as president of the United
States now this is a horrific
circumstance and the reason why is
because William Striker is a religious
fundamentalist this guy leads a group
called The purifiers their whole Charter
is that they believe it's their mission
from God to destroy the mutant
population now William Striker can't
simply just Rebrand the United States
Army as like the purifiers and then just
start taking out mutants everywhere they
go there is the game of politics and so
in the fifth year the United States
Congress passes the mutant Control Act
this is exactly what it sounds like it
is a bill passed by Congress to
basically restrict the rights of the
mutant population Now Matt Murdoch
Daredevil ends up approaching the
Supreme Court and makes an argument in
essentially saying that because the
mutant population are still citizens of
the United States and are at their very
core human it's restricting the rights
of US citizens I.E it violates the US
Constitution the United States Supreme
Court agrees with him and they overturn
the mutant control act now in the
original Days of Future Past we didn't
know that it was Matt Murdoch who had
done this we just simply knew that the
Supreme Court overturned the mutant
Control Act the other part is that in
the original Days of Future Past there
was no reason to believe William Striker
was President largely because his
character had not been created in Marvel
Comics by that point in time but it does
make sense right like the original
depiction of the president and then
William Striker they look very similar
and so by year six the United States
government does exactly what it did in
the original Days of Future Past story
it launches The Sentinel program now
something to understand about this whole
Sentinel program and the history behind
it is super fascinating you have had a
guy by the name of bolivard tras
bolivard tras was the one who originally
created the Sentinels but these are not
necessarily bolard tras Sentinels they
are but they're not the Sentinels that
you're familiar with from like X-Men the
Animated Series and so on and so forth
that's Steven Lang not to be confused
with Scott Lang the two of them are not
related but basically after Bard tras
was originally defeated in the X-Men
Comics The Sentinel program was handed
over to Steven Lang who basically
redesigned them updated them with newer
technology and sent them out into the
world such as it is it doesn't look like
Steven Lang has any involvement here so
effectively they're using the Steven
Lang design but Bolivar tras and the
tras Dynasty are essentially the ones
behind it but by year 11 the Sentinels
are sent out into the world or really
into the United States itself but
instead of just immediately attacking
everything what they end up doing is
just kind of walking around the idea is
that they're there quote unquote for
safety right to to be a kind of
non-human police force what the
Sentinels are actually doing is scanning
and cataloging mutants studying their
powers learning what they're capable of
and so by year 18 we end up in Stamford
Connecticut now for those of you guys
who are familiar with Stanford
Connecticut you pretty much already know
what's about to go down here for those
of you guys who aren't Stamford
Connecticut was the Catalyst for the
Civil War event in Marvel Comics
basically things transpire almost the
exact same way but it doesn't lead to
Civil War instead what ended up
happening here is that because of the
passage of the mutant Control Act The
Avengers resigned in solidarity with the
mutant population exactly how that is in
solidarity of mutants I don't
necessarily know because I don't see the
Avengers fighting alongside them right
so what you end up getting by the
federal government is basically the
creation of the Defenders now this is
not the first time in Marvel Comics that
the federal government has created a
federally sanctioned superhero team and
in fact if my memory serves me the
original X Factor from Bob Leighton and
then eventually Walter and L Simonson
yes that team was composed of like the
original X-Men just on a team of their
own when Marvel relaunched everything in
the 1990s and you got Uncanny X-Men and
then X-Men volume to xfactor ended up
getting a new roster with like strong
guy and people like that but they were a
government sanctioned superhero team so
it's not that uncommon to see and you
even saw it more recently in the events
of like dark rain right and so on and so
forth but the kicker here is that while
these guys look like Avengers they're
not a really good example of this is
that instead of Steve Rogers is Captain
America it's John Walker I.E us agent
instead of Iron Man you basically have
obadia stain operating as the Iron
Monger making himself look like Iron Man
but the thing about this is that as far
as the X-Men are concerned it's just
them fighting a villainous group out in
Stamford but then Wolverine picks up on
a scent and he realizes something's
wrong here right like there's something
going on specifically he figures out
that when it comes to Nitro his sense
all wrong right that he's got some kind
of chemical or drug in his system and
that's when we realize it's basically
just like it was at the beginning of
civil war that Nitro has taken mutant
growth hormone basically a drug that
amplifies the powers of mutants and
because nitro's ability is to
self-detonate and let off a massive
explosion without destroying himself is
exactly what happens here he blows up
the entirety of Stanford Connecticut
boom president of the United States
declares martial law now here's where I
kind of disagree with exactly what's
going on here right we do get Valerie
Cooper who's the office of National
Emergency liaison for mutant Affairs for
those of you guys who don't know about
Valerie Cooper this girl was like
hardcore man like the commission on
superum activities if you guys remember
like the old Chris Claremont stuff from
back in the 70s and 80s that was all
Valerie Cooper in effect she was kind of
like the liaison to the superhero
community and she was the one that would
keep them on a tight leash as far as the
federal government was concerned because
back at the time when Days of Future
Past was originally written the general
consensus when it came to like the
entirety of the superhero community and
you saw it like the Fantastic 4D the
X-Men Captain America comics so on and
so forth is that the federal government
was very much cracking down on
superheroes being able to have this kind
of like free reign out in the world and
all the kind of stuff that came with it
where I disagree with what's happening
is we've got Henry Peter grick and
Wilson Fisk along with Simon tras when
it came to the original Days of Future
Past event there was no internal human
Circle and in fact the Sentinels had
basically just become self-aware what I
do like is that it looks like they're
kind of starting with this but they're
not going to end with this because what
Simon tras does is he speaks up and he
says okay we may have an unintended
consequence here and when the question
is asked what's the unintended
consequence he says the sentinel's
primary directive is to maintain order
and protect the populace I'm concerned
they might determine that the most
efficient means to do so is to simply
just take over and when the question is
asked what does this have to do with
Stanford Connecticut the response of
Simon is martial law means the
suspension of civil rights taking
control of America is certainly easier
once democracy is on a timeout after all
isn't that why the four of us
orchestrated Stamford and so where
Wilson Fisk speaks up and he says you're
saying that you think at some point the
Sentinels will decide we're working for
them instead of the other way around the
response of tras is I think they may
already have done that now here's the
reason why that's so important in the
Days of Future Past comic when the
Sentinels took over while we weren't
explicitly told exactly what their line
of logic was it was pretty simple and in
fact X-Men the Animated Series explained
it perfectly that when the Sentinels
were tasked with basically seeing
mutants as the enemy it was a logical
choice for Humanity and illogical choice
for the Sentinels because Sentinels are
just robots they just follow orders
right they really don't understand
Nuance with Humanity we routinely look
for reasons to justify our belief
systems even if our justifications are
nonsensical right we can just make up
any reason we want to and then go
forward believing that for a robot it
makes no logical sense and so the
Sentinels would look at the mutant
population they would look at the human
population and they would say by all
standards of measurement mutants are
humans therefore if our task is to
control the mutant population
that means control the human population
and that's why in the original Days of
Future Past storyline the Sentinels took
over everything and in fact a perfect
example of the nonsensical logic of
humanity comes in the form of Simon tras
debating Steve Rogers on national
television and what ends up happening is
Steve Rogers presents basically The
Logical argument right the one that you
or I or anybody would expect to see
which is to say what's the difference
between like The Avengers or the X-Men
or the Fantastic Four right like the
Avengers and Fantastic 4 routinely save
the world and we're championed as Heroes
the X-Men do the same thing and you
basically see them as like criminals
people that need to be contained and
controlled but the response to Simon
tras is we're talking about two
distinctly different things number one
The Avengers all gained their powers
through some kind of external means you
Steve Rogers got your powers by way of
the super soldier serum that the
Incredible Hulk was a result of gamma
radiation Thor is a Godly being so on
and so forth with mutants their powers
developed during puberty so are we
really supposed to just kind of stand
idly by as a 13-year-old who has no real
understanding of the full totality of
their actions and the impact that they
have who has the ability to simply just
wipe out an entire school system with
some kind of an explosion or shoot
lasers out of his eyes or read the minds
of other people do we just kind of let
that kid exist like who knows what might
happen in that circumstance are you
really going to tell me that we don't
have the right to be be afraid right
that regulating these human weapons
isn't the safe and necessary thing to do
this is not Prejudice Captain it's
common sense and that's really where the
Crux of the entire argument came from
that if mutants are people who develop
their powers at such a time in their
life to where they can't truly
understand the consequences of their
actions should they be allowed to just
roam free out there in the world or
should they be regulated and controlled
the same way that we control guns and
different things along those lines
that's where the arguments get
interesting because then as people we
would just kind of arbitrarily say but
like they're human though so we can't do
that because there's just an arbitrary
difference that we've created between a
dangerous human and like a dangerous
weapon right you know so it's really
interesting how this whole thing unfolds
but where the heroes really start to die
really comes by way of Spider-Man and
the reason why is because what we're
told is that as time progressed humanity
stopped differentiating between Heroes
and mutants and what initially started
out as anti-mutant fervor became
anti-hero fervor they started going
after everybody and so there's like this
great big huge protest that erupts
between mutants and humans Spider-Man
steps in he tries to quell everything
and they beat him to death they
literally kill Spider-Man now one of the
things that's kind of discussed there is
that Peter Parker could have stood up to
them and he could have fought his way
out but the concern is that he didn't
really want to hurt anybody I got to
tell you man if I'm Peter Parker and I'm
being attacked by a mob of people
everybody's going to get one right
everybody's getting attacked I'm making
it out of there just be glad I don't
kill you in the
process right but then following that
you pick up with professor Charles
Xavier and this is where things get
interesting because what's been going on
in the midst of all of this is Magneto
is making his move and where this does
kind of seem to come out of left field
the logic of Magneto is actually
incredibly sound here because with the
X-Men trying to find Magneto and Magneto
going after like the world's nuclear
arsenals of course Shield steps in
Shield AIDS the X-Men in helping to
locate the Brotherhood of evil mutants
but then the group goes directly after
Magneto and this is one of those
instances where I guarantee you guys are
going to look at this and you're going
to be like Magneto is 100% right because
what ends up happening is where Xavier
says no we can't do this Magneto you're
playing into their hands they want to
see a violent mutant out there doing
violent things to justify their belief
systems the response of Magneto to
Charles Xavier is you're talking as if
they're using any kind of logic they've
made up their mind the mutant Control
Act has been passed like they're
targeting us there's no more like trying
to stop this from happening there's no
more like reasoning with them and trying
to get them to understand right he's
like they are counting on nothing except
your plant acquiescence and he says they
pass laws to make criminals of us and
you do nothing they send out Sentinels
to march across our country and you do
nothing they use us as a pretext to
declare martial law and you do nothing
tell me Charles all these men and women
so many enemies who hate and fear us and
yet the only person you and your ex-men
stand against is me and so it's such a
phenomenal argument here because the
response of the X-Men is like we're
coming after you because you're trying
to take over the world and Magneto's
whole stance is to protect us from them
because this is no longer a debate or
this is no longer a discussion that
could be had it's open War right are we
fighting in the streets no not
necessarily but they've made move
they're Waging War against us and he
says they'll come for us and for all of
us and we'll tell ourselves as we always
have that it's okay they'll brand us
like cattle and we'll tell ourselves
that it's no different than a driver's
license they'll put us in ghettos and
we'll tell ourselves it's just for a
little while then they'll put us in
camps and we'll tell ourselves it will
end soon we'll be right about that much
at least you think I'm speaking of the
future I am not I'm telling you you
about the past I know it can happen
because I've watched it happen Magneto
is literally looking at a repeat of
everything that happened during World
War II in Germany and he's not wrong
right that in a lot of ways even as the
story is kind of being told in hindsight
Xavier is being seen as a guy who has
this naive optimism right that in the
face of a asteroid moments from crashing
into the Earth and annihilating all all
life across the planet there's still
hope that the day can be saved we're
well far past that point there's nothing
to be done here right the end is not and
so what we end up doing is jumping
aboard a basically a plane which is a
response to Magneto which is to say the
government's trying to move these
different nuclear weapons to a more
secure location because they realize
Magneto is going after that the problem
is that Jason winguard Mastermind a
mutant that has the ability to
manipulate the five senses is basically
aboard this plane so when you have kitty
pride and Jean Gray and Cyclops who get
here this takes place after the events
of dark Phoenix why does that matter
because Jason winguard in that story had
screwed with the mind of genan gray and
led her to becoming the dark Phoenix in
the first place and so as I don't really
know if I would call it payback but kind
of that victimization that she
experienced she attacks Jason winguard
and in fact she actually kills him but
in the process she inadvertently
activates the nuclear weapons with 15
seconds counting down these bombs go off
no one's really able to keep it
contained but Cyclops is basically
phased by Kitty Pride meaning she's able
to make him intangible and so while it
doesn't really kill him it does burn his
eyes out of his head so they actually
have to remove his eyeballs at a future
point in time meaning he has no powers
whatsoever and so following this what
you end up doing is you pick up at
basically the funeral of Jean Gray right
that everybody's kind of there in
attendance but you effectively have
Magneto who shows up who wasn't
necessarily welcomed and in fact while a
fight breaks out initially between
Wolverine and Magneto and Wolverine
pulls a plastic gun with polymer bullets
that Magneto wouldn't be able to stop
Cyclops decides he wants to hear what
Magneto has to say and in effect it's a
ceasefire right it's a truce that it is
really Magneto and Xavier agreeing to
kind of work together but for the most
part to try things Xavier's way and to
see if there's a way to bring some kind
of peaceful resolution to this entire
conflict spoiler alert there's not right
so what is a happening is we get this
really really cool monologue right where
we're told despite everything the
professor never hated Magneto it was
worse than that his heart broke for
never being able to bring his friend to
his side Magneto was right of course
about things getting worse the first
thing president Striker did was get
Congress to reinstate the mutant Control
Act this time the Supreme Court chose
not to stop it under the mutant Control
Act the government began placing mutants
in relocation centers quote unquote for
for their own protection some mutants
and their families fled North to Canada
but most stayed in America under the
mistaken belief that things would
eventually get better and they didn't
right Magneto's prophecy came to pass
because if humanity is really good at
doing anything it's just constantly
repeating cycles of events that have
happened in the past especially if we
never learn from them and so what ends
up happening is that by year 19 Henry
Peter grick shows up to professor
Charles Xavier and he essentially tells
him we've got warrants for every single
one of your X-Men and you to be taken to
a relocation Center so you can either
come willingly or you can come
forcefully but Xavier causes Bluff
because what he realizes is that there
are the Optics of what would happen if
the human population just attacked the
entirety of the X-Men mansion even all
of the Angry and anti-mutant feror
that's out there people wouldn't
necessarily side with like an unprovoked
attack against innocent people
especially if the X-Men just did nothing
and allow themselves to be killed on
National Television they wouldn't really
be martyrs per se although they kind of
would because what that could
potentially do is turn popular sentiment
or public sentiment against the federal
government then you have 300 million
people who have all waged war against
you and so in response to that what
Henry Peter grick and Valerie Cooper do
is they bring in general Thunderbolt
Ross right the guy who traditionally
goes after the Incredible Hulk and they
task him with launching an attack attack
against the X-Men right and then in turn
trying to spin it in order to make it
look like the X-Men attacked first
general Thunderbolt Ross chooses not to
because despite how he may be portrayed
in the X-Men Comics he is a man of Honor
right he wouldn't really go after the
X-Men unprovoked or attack people
unprovoked more so than that right the
posy comatus Act of 1878 the United
States Army or the United States
military cannot enforce laws within the
borders of the United States so
ultimately General Thunderbolt Ross is
relieved of command somebody else is put
in his place and the attack goes down
the main X-Men roster are basically led
to a conflict out in m Island so the
entirety of the X-Men mansion is
basically laid empty in response to that
while that happens William Striker and
his forces attack the X-Men mansion
Professor Xavier is there to witness all
the death and destruction Iceman is one
of the first to fall right he's just
grabbed by a sentinel and he's one part
melted one part destroyed right but
literally just shattered and that's the
end of him Xavier tries to use his
telepathy to take over the minds of the
various soldiers who were standing out
there and are intending to invade the
entire Mansion but Frank Simpson also
known as nuke who's historically been
part of weapons plus this guy fires off
a shot and kills Xavier on the spot
following that you have guys like
Nightcrawler who were destroyed by
Sentinels it's just like Michael
Corleone at the end of Godfather right
like executing the heads of the five
families it's a multi-prong strike
against everybody except for the core
X-Men so the only real X-Men that you
have left here are like storm Colossus
Forge Kitty Pride right like wolver rain
that's more or less it but the
leadership is essentially gone and so
what ends up happening is that in this
moment of realizing that things are
going to go belly up that things are in
the darkest of times there's a kind of
connection that's been forming for quite
some time between Kitty pride and
Colossus and the two of them get married
but one of the funny things is that were
told it would be like the last happy day
that anybody would really experience for
any measure of time because following
that for the X-Men it's just basically
gorilla Warfare tactics they're jumping
from one location to the next by year 20
they're in madapur and they're just
moving from one safe location constantly
underground they never really can
operate out of a singular base of
operations more so than that the
Sentinels have evolved to a point where
now they're sending out nimrods why does
that matter because the Nimrod Sentinel
model was a version of The Sentinel that
not only could detect what a mutant's
power was but could also develop a
countermeasure to it and figure out what
psychological or emotional weaknesses
they would have and use it against them
right to fight against a nimrod was to
fight against a sentinel that could
attack you both physically mentally and
emotionally it was one of the most
devastating Sentinels to ever exist out
there imagine fighting three more so
than that and the initial attack against
the X-Men mansion Summers the daughter
of Jean Gray and cyclops in this
universe was one of the only people to
survive but she was taken by the US
government specifically Ahab but she was
taken and she was turned into a Hound
what does that mean a Hound is a mutant
that was used to hunt other mutants and
because she was such a powerful telepath
it made perfect sense she would be used
for that purpose one of the first people
she attacks is Storm now what's also
crazy about this is Franklin Richards
does exist in this universe and he did
exist in Days of Future Past the
difference is that Franklin Richard's
reality warping abilities were nowhere
near as advanced as they became during
like Jonathan Hickman's fantastic 4run
when he was older a lot of that was
because when Franklin was younger Reed
Richards put mental blocks in his head
to keep him from accessing the full
totality of his powers more or less it
looks like during Days of Future Past
those mental blocks were never removed
so he's just like a really capable
telepath and telekinetic but we don't
know if he'll ever tap into his power in
the original Days of Future Past story
he never did he never accessed the full
totality of his reality warping
abilities he did in Days of Future
present but he never did in Days of
Future Past and so where Storm and
Franklin Richards are both taken into
custody by the US government and taken
into an internment camp Forge and Beast
are two of the last X-Men remaining and
Beast agrees to stay there and to help
Forge face off against the Sentinels
Beast is eradicated in an instant he's
destroyed the Sentinels in turn take
Forge and the only thing we're told is
that the Fate they have for him is a
fate worse than death and so following
that you switch over to year 22 right
we're told in the years that followed
the Sentinels only stepped up their
aggression mutants were either branded
with IM badges imprisoned in camps or
hunted by hounds non-mutant Heroes tried
to stand against the rising fascism but
not without cost because what isend up
going on is the Fantastic Four arrive on
the scene and basically encounter Rachel
Summers and because Rachel Summers has
had history with Franklin the two of
them were like a romantic couple they
had a whole history together and
everything the Fantastic Four tried to
use that connection in order to try to
bring her back to reality she basically
attacks Ben Grim she kills the thing she
destroys Reed Richards and then Susan
storm is killed by Ahab right like the
Fantastic Four wiped out in one Fell
Swoop then you jump to year 26 and you
pick up with Banshee right sea Cassidy
this guy that has the ability to admit a
scream his power sucks and basically he
dies right because because he's one of
the crappiest mutants to ever exist in
the history of Marvel Comics guy can
scream and fly raho so when it comes to
like this guy's death this guy's
destroyed Rachel Summers jumps back onto
the scene again and goes after Kitty
Pride this time Rachel is basically
taken out by Bishop now why Bishop's
here I have no clue it's one of the
weirdest things and in fact it flies in
the face of everything we know about the
original Days of Future Past story
because what is up happening is Bishop
is the one that contacts Rachel Summers
a really contacts Kitty pride and tells
her that Rachel is the key to saving
this entire timeline and preventing this
timeline from ever coming into the
future and in fact he says he's from an
alternate future right another timeline
which is similar to Days of Future Past
honestly it feels like Bishop's just
thrown in here for the sake of throwing
him in here but what he does is he tells
her exactly what's supposed to happen in
order to save this timeline now assuming
that this concludes the way the original
Days of Future Past did which I don't
even know how it is that it's going to
conclude that way everything just kind
of feels so different now in essence
Rachel Summers would send the mind of
kitty Pride into the past to warn the
X-Men of what was going to happen the
X-Men would stop the assassination of
Robert Kelly and it would save the day
but I have no clue if that's what's
actually going to happen or not and
perhaps even there's no saving this
timeline what they do end up doing
though is they basically cure the
brainwashing of Rachel Summers right get
her back to her normal self and then
send her back in as an agent that's
basically been missing for some time but
has finally returned that the
brainwashing process is effectively
recomened this time with mental blocks
that Rachel herself is able to keep in
place so she never fully succumbs to it
and in response to that Rachel Summers
does kill Ahab but she's captured by the
Sentinels this explains how it is that
in the original Days of Future Past
story Rachel Summers was in an
internment camp because one of the
things to know all these characters that
you see here right like Colossus Kitty
Pride Rachel Summers storm Magneto and
so on they all end up in a concentration
camp right where mutants are basically
being held with Magneto it's going to be
a little bit interesting here in a
second because I'm curious how you take
it but what we do is we switch over to
year 28 and where you have Colossus and
kitty Pride who were on the Run trying
to escape these Sentinels that are
coming after them the Sentinels wipe out
their kids literally the Sentinels take
their kids out just completely and
totally incinerate them following that
Colossus initially wants to go after the
Sentinels But ultimately doesn't now
while we're not explicitly told here
what it looks like is the Sentinels have
officially taken over that Humanity no
longer has any involvement in any of
this the Sentinels have taken over
everything there doesn't really seem to
be a clear delineation as to when that
happened but at the very least that
seems to be the case and so by year 29
right 29 years after all this has
started you pick up in the internment
camp and of course you do have Franklin
Richard Shir and you've got Rachel
Summers who more or less make amends and
everything kind of gets sorted but what
you do at that point is you jump over to
Wolverine who's met by the arrival of
Magneto and the two of them have never
really reconciled their differences
after the death of Jean and so this is
like the first time they've met since
the funeral and that initial
conversation when Magneto walked away
but one of the things to know about the
original Days of Future Past is that
Wolverine was actually working with a
North American resistance meaning he and
other mutants that were out there that
hadn't been captured were operating
inside Canada which largely became a
kind of safe haven for those mutants
that didn't stay in North America and he
would occasionally travel to the United
States which would basically become a
safe haven for those mutants that didn't
stay in the United States and that in
turn he would travel back and forth
between Canada and the states either
helping people escape the us or bringing
information to those who needed it and
taking pot shots against the Sentinels
where he could when he could but what
Magneto does here and kind of a weird
decision I don't really know why Marvel
did this but they basically say that
like the Sentinels have found a way to
weaponize the planet Itself by causing
like environmental Calamity right it
kind of seems unnecessary seems a little
over the top and seems like it's
injected here for no real logical reason
but they're basically using Scarlet
Witch to do it so Magneto leading a
resistance force consisting of uh wolver
rain and Jubilee ends up going in
rescuing Wanda maximoff Wanda's taken by
wolverin out of the entire facility but
not before she destroys the machine and
kind of tells Magneto keep on fighting
whatever you do just keep going and so
what happened is that somewhere along
the line basically in what was formerly
asteroid M which was at one point a base
of operations for Magneto that it is now
become a prison for the mutant
population now that's one of the big
differences between the original Days of
Future Past and this one and the
original Days of Future Past and in fact
we'll actually get to that point in the
story that main internment camp was
actually in New York right but what
ended up going on here is that when the
Sentinels first started capturing
mutants and they set up this internment
camp that what they did is they created
a kind of central Hub right a kind of
Mainframe computer and that computer
controlled the inhibitor collars that
all the mutants wore right the collars
that basically shut their powers down
some kind of a riot took place where the
mutants were able to destroy the Central
Computer they reactivated their powers
and they went to war against the
Sentinels and for a moment they were
winning for a moment they were winning
and it looked like the day was saved but
then reinforcements arrived now this is
another big difference right in this
moment what you see here is a
combination of Mark 1 and Mark 2
Sentinels along with nimrods now the big
difference between the original Days of
Future Past and this Days of Future Past
is that in the original story the reason
why the Sentinels were able to take over
North America and really wipe out most
of the superhero Community is because
there were just so many of them right
like they just multiplied like crazy so
there were thousands tens of thousands
of Sentinels traveling around North
America so any attempt by any remaining
members of the Superhuman or even human
population that tried to fight Sentinels
found themselves in a war of attrition
the Sentinels would just keep coming and
coming and coming eventually these guys
would be worn down and they would either
be captured or killed the Nimrod
Sentinels didn't appear until much later
on in the Days of Future Past Universe
we didn't figure that out until the
story Days of Future present which we'll
talk about a little bit as we get
towards the end of this because it's
really cool the important thing here is
that there were seemingly only two
mutants Left Alive in this Riot the
first one was Laura Kenny x23 who pretty
much all of you guys know about and the
other one was sink right Everett Thomas
now Everett Thomas has grown more
popular at least in more recent years
since Jonathan Hickman's reworking of
the X-Men Mythos but this guy is
ridiculously overpowered especially now
because his powers have evolved but in
essence he can duplicate the powers of
anybody who's near him a great big
caveat that was adjusted or kind of a
boost to his power that was given
recently is that there's no limit to how
long he can hold on to that power for so
he could walk through like a field of
mutants copy all their abilities and
then hold on to those Powers seemingly
for the rest of his life so the guys
like Peter Petrelli from Heroes back in
the day if you guys remember that show
and so this whole event is actually told
to Franklin Richards Magneto storm
Rachel Summers Colossus it's told to
them by Kitty Pride she's kind of
hearing it all or at least repeating it
all to them because she heard it
secondhand it just happened over there
off the coast of San Francisco nobody
really knows for sure who survived or
anything but following that whole event
that's when you start to fall more in
line with the traditional Days of Future
Past story where each one of the mutants
had an inhibitor collar that had to be
turned off individually so there was no
Mainframe to destroy the only way to get
your powers back was to destroy your own
inhibitor collar but if you did that it
would detonate and it would kill you so
just because of the fact that none of
the mutants wanted to die they were
stuck with really these inhibitor collar
around their necks and so what's going
on here is really kind of like this
dovetail into the original conclusion of
Days of Future Past where Kitty Pride if
you recall in the previous video and
again you'll find a link to that
playlist at the end of this video Kitty
Pride had come across Bishop now Bishop
traditionally a time traveling mutant
did not appear in the original Days of
Future Past because he was not
introduced in Marvel at that point in
time right he wasn't introduced in
Marvel until what is it Uncanny X-Men
286 289 maybe it was 287 something like
that uh but he was introduced much later
on right in the 80s late 80s going into
the early 90s but the kicker about all
this is that Bishop had told Kitty Pride
you guys need to find a way to time
travel it's the only way for you to save
your current Universe now before a lot
of you guys kind of get dismissive and
you're like oh my god really time travel
hyenes don't worry Marvel does not
disappoint they do not disappoint and in
fact the ending to this is not like the
original Days of Future Past that's the
one hint I'll give you and so what this
does is this transitions over to the
Atlantic Ocean and the reason why is
because in order for this plan to work
these remaining X-Men right Kitty pride
and everybody else they need to be able
to deactivate their inhibitor collar but
Reed Richards of the Fantastic 4 is dead
he was killed in the last video Iron Man
was killed in the last video there's no
one out there right Hank Pim Ant-Man all
these guys Bruce Banner there's nobody
else out there with the level of
wherewithal and the technological
prowess to deactivate these callers
except for one guy Forge now for those
of the guys who are familiar with Forge
and I imagine there's probably a few
people who are not Forge is basically a
mutant whose power basically turns him
into Tony Stark that's really what it is
if you take away his mutant power he
doesn't really know how to do anything
but with his mutant power he's just this
genius te technological inventor but
because of his capabilities the
Sentinels didn't kill him instead
they've been using him as a guy that can
help them Advance their own machinery
and Advance their own capabilities now
this is also another big difference
between the original Days of Future Past
if this was part of that story it was
never readily explained in Chris
claremont's original run and Uncanny
X-Men 141 and 142 the only thing we
really knew is that because the
Sentinels were technologically advanced
and because they were self-aware they
took over the backer building the former
home base of the Fantastic 4 and they Ed
all the technology in the Baer building
to enhance themselves but because they
were just machines right they were like
the machines from The Matrix right like
the longer they existed the more
advanced they became just by
understanding their own components and
evolving from there right self-aware and
autonomous so it is a kind of cool
little addition to this but because
Forge is so necessary here word had been
sent to Wolverine who's part of the
Canadian resistance which is an accurate
part of the original Days of Future Past
and that the idea here is that he would
basically sneak in and he would get
forged out now the reason why this works
both in the original and in this one is
because it's Wolverine right Marvel is
actually building off Daniel Way's
Wolverine Origins run that's how this
works if you guys aren familiar with
that Wolverine Origins by Daniel way was
the story where Wolverine got all of his
memories back after the events of House
of M and so he went on this kind of like
war path but one of the things that he
had done is he had successfully snuck
into the White house and then eventually
left and did it without being caught and
so the guy can get in and out of
basically anywhere but once he gets in
here because Sentinels are not like
humans meaning there's very very little
that they ever actually miss Wolverine
gets forged he basically helps him at
least to try to initiate the Escape but
he tells him getting in is not the
problem it's getting out now you would
think a way in is a way out but whatever
means he used to get in here is
seemingly not available to him as
they're trying to leave but the nimrods
immediately pick up on what it is that
these guys are doing right they're here
and they're trying to Stage an escape
and so because of the fact that there's
really no way out for both of them Forge
does the only thing he can do right he
says I'll stay behind to destroy this
terminal so the Sentinels will not know
what I've designed and then I'll cover
your Escape now here's the kicker behind
this Forge has been working on more than
simply just a way to deactivate
inhibitor collar he's been working on a
kind of Technology that would actually
allow the entirety of the remaining
mutant population to escape their
confinement and wage war against the
Sentinels but here's the caveat to this
there's a ticking Time Bomb here quite
literally the rest of the world has come
to the realization of the threat that
the Sentinels po because remember what
we covered in the last video is that
despite the fact that Sentinels were
activated by humans to track down
mutants and to basically capture them in
North America the Sentinels rationalized
with the only real logic that they could
use that because mutants were at the
next stage in human evolution mutants
are humans and so Sentinels track down
both and they took over the entirety of
North America the rest of the world
right especially Europe came to the
realization if the Sentinels Escape
North America and they're able to impose
their will across the rest of the world
everybody will be captured every single
human every single superpowered being
the whole nine yards so what the rest of
the world is currently planning is a
nuclear strike against North America to
eradicate the entirety of the Sentinel
population which would happen right they
would be able to destroy pretty much all
Sentinels and even if they didn't
destroy all the Sentinels they would
wipe out enough that their numbers would
count for nothing so it's one of those
really like okay we have only so long to
do this and so one of the things that
goes on here is that the Sentinels
themselves what they've been doing is
that because they had become more
advanced as time had gone on that they
had basically become larger and larger
and because of that there were certain
tasks that they simply just were not fit
to do they couldn't really go out there
into the world and scavenge for parts
anymore to grab resources and things
that were needed for Forge to do his
work or whatever else and so what they
were doing is they were grabbing mutants
and they were sending them out and
saying get these components get what we
need and then come back right if you
don't if you're not back within 3 hours
we'll activate your inhibitor collars
and we'll kill you right that's
basically it and so the mutants were
more like right Aaron boys Aaron girls
that's the purpose that they served but
what the Sentinels didn't realize is
that this offered the mutant population
this kind of unsupervised time where
they can actually actively work against
the Sentinels themselves now one of the
things that's kind of cool here is that
it almost gives the Sentinels this air
of arrogance right like who are these
mutants to believe they could overtake
us and in fact that's accurate right in
the original Days of Future Past and in
this one as the Sentinels become more
self-aware they begin to develop almost
human emotions they become arrogant
right that's kind of how they began to
evolve and began to grow and so what
they end up doing is Kitty Pride meets
with Wolverine he passes the thumb drive
off to her and the project or what it
was that Forge was working on was
basically a Jammer so instead of simply
just shutting down an inhibitor collar
that this Jammer would be able to shut
down multiple collar at once which is a
far more productive method of allowing
mutants the ability to use their powers
because instead of like running around
with a little key right and like trying
to make contact with 50 little mutants
and trying to turn off their inhibitor
cers and so on they just take this thing
sit it down turn it on and everybody can
use their powers now right and one Fell
Swoop the entirety of the mutant
population goes back to the way they
were without having to worry about the
inability to being able to use their
abilities against the Sentinels and so
this is when they really start to get
into the realm of time travel because
much like the original Days of Future
Past story because Rachel Summers is the
daughter of Cyclops and Jean Gray in
Days of Future Past she has vast
telepathic powers and in fact this kind
of brings in right really kind of dovet
tales nicely into Days of Future present
Days of Future present while it's not
part of this story it seemingly leads
into it but Days of Future present was a
story that was told in Marvel Comics
back in the 80s that basically explained
how it was that Rachel Summers arrived
in the main Marvel Universe and we'll
talk about that a little more as we get
towards the end of this because you guys
are going to kind of find yourselves in
a sort of precarious position I'm
curious to see how you guys respond to
it if you never read the original Days
of Future Past but this whole plan this
was the idea of Bishop right it was like
Bishop's idea have someone send your
mind into the past into the younger body
of yourself because if your physical
body goes back there you could get stuck
any number of things could go wrong but
by sending your mind into the past
especially with like a telepath like
Rachel Summers she serves as an anchor
she can yank you back right it's a
tether that kind of thing and so Kitty
Pride's mind goes into the body of her
younger self and for those of you guys
who read the original Days of Future
Past this is all familiar to you so I'm
going to cover this more for the people
who never read the original story so
you're not left hanging because it's a
landmark Story the most iconic X-Men
Story Ever Told honestly I think it's
better than the dark Phoenix Saga I'm
being quite Frank with you guys but
that's because I love it when there's
like death pandemonium and the end of
times in Marvel Comics when everybody
dies I love the stories and so Kitty
Pride's mind going into the body of her
younger self when she was like what like
15 I think it was maybe like like 12 or
13 when she first join the X-Men she's
able to stop the assassination of
Senator Robert Kelly and as soon as that
happens her mind is yanked back and so
one of the things that is a little bit
different here is that unlike the
original Days of Future Past where she
goes back and kind of meets with the
X-Men and gets to know them and all that
kind of stuff you get that to a degree
here but it's kind of passed over super
fast and I I think a lot of that is
because Marvel's kind of relying on
people to understand the original Days
of Future Past all that really means
here is that when Kitty's mind went back
into the past in the original Days of
Future Past story that she actually
spent a few days like a week or so with
the X-Men basically saying hey this is
going to happen at this point in time
here in a little while you guys need to
be prepared for it right she actually
spent time learned about the X-Men
different things along those lines and
then took those lessons back with her
into the future and that's exactly what
happens here but there was also a plan B
because there was no guarantee that her
going into the past and changing it
would change the future and we'll talk
about why that matters here in a second
because Marvel invokes Branch universe
theory both in the original Days of
Future Past and in this one and so what
happens as part of this plan B is that
with the inhibitor collars deactivated
by way of the Jammer it allows them to
remove the inhibitor collar proper and
then stage their attempt Escape against
the Sentinels now much like the original
Days of Future Past basically everybody
dies right like storm is able to help
them save off the Sentinels for a little
while Magneto stays behind in his
wheelchair to basically cover their
Escape right like it's one of those
things where they're kind of like I mean
look his wheelchair would have slowed us
down he made the right call to stay
behind right the Sentinels come out of
nowhere they annihilate Franklin Richard
here's a big kicker because this is
something that a lot of people asked
about with Franklin Richards in the
original Days of Future Past and the
stories that came after because one of
the things that a lot of people don't
know about Franklin is that with Days of
Future Past he was just introduced as
the son of Reed and Susan but his whole
like crazy level reality warping Powers
right that wasn't until much later on so
a lot of people asked the question if
Franklin Richards by virtue of the
establishment of his reality warping
Powers when he was an adult if he was so
incredibly powerful why is it he was
destroyed by the Sentinels the only real
explanation Marvel and even us as the
fan base were able to offer was twofold
either one in this universe he never
attained that level of power he never
really became this crazy reality warping
character or if he did none of the
events transpired in his history that
led to him realizing he had that power
right so the old Fantastic 4 story when
he was frustrated working with a Rubik
Cube and aged himself up into an adult
what is it Fantastic 4 145 or 146
something like that that story never
happened right so like he never realize
he could alter reality none of those
things took place The abraxis Saga never
took place Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers never took place right because
most of the superheroes were dead by
that point and so again it's one of
these things where he was a telepath and
telekinetic but that was basically it he
didn't have his crazy reality warping
Powers but the long and short of this is
that this guy's destroyed right so two
of them are down Rachel summer is being
the love interest of Franklin she kind
of stays behind a little bit right and
just kind of continues to attack the
Sentinels using a combination of her
telepathy and telekinesis which creates
a kind of psionic blast that just blows
the head off of one of these Sentinels
but again their goal is to basically
keep moving forward is to find a way to
attack the sentinel's main base of
operations I.E the backer building and
so as they get there much like the
original Days of Future Past right
wolver rain as soon as he enters into
the backer building one of the Sentinels
immediately attacks him and that's
because they knew they were coming right
the Sentinels were well aware of the
fact that they were coming now what
really went on here is that Wolverine
and those guys ended up tripping a
sensor right that really alerted the
Sentinels to their presence and the
Sentinels just incinerated Wolverine on
the spot now this is one of the other
things about Days of Future Past when
the story was originally done and what
this story is really kind of building on
is the fact that Wolverine's healing
Factor had not become what it is now
back during the days of Chris clont
X-Men Wolverine's healing Factor was
more practical than anything else right
it wasn't like it is in Civil War where
his whole body's annihilated and he just
heals right and then like that's it and
his healing Factor becomes like a plot
device to a story no no no know it was a
fairly reasonable healing factor and so
that's why in this story he's
incinerated entirely and he doesn't heal
back from it right he's incinerated all
the way down to his adamantium skeleton
it's not to the point where it's like
well all you need is a cell and then
he'll heal back from everything no it's
not like that anymore of course storm
launches an attack Storm's impaled with
a spear and then Colossus goes to make
an attack on one of the Sentinels now
unlike the original Days of Future Past
where all you see with Colossus is that
he goes to attack one of the Sentinels
and seemingly killed and thrown out of a
window this is where things begin to
shift because unlike the original Days
of Future Past where it's the end of
times for everybody Magneto
survived Magneto made it out against
those four Sentinels and why wouldn't he
right and I think that's one of the best
decisions about this is because like
sure Magneto's older but like four
Sentinels no man like four Sentinels are
not enough power to take out the master
of magnetism right like there entire
body is composed of of an element he can
use as a weapon like literally metal
they are their own destruction in the
eyes of Magneto so that guy took out
those four Sentinels he arrives on the
scene and then he goes after these four
Sentinels and in fact he seemingly seems
to issue kind of like an EMP to a degree
but one of the Sentinels which is
basically in the process of failing and
deactivating grabs Colossus and then
squeezes him to the point where his body
basically just crushes now that is one
of the things to understand about
Colossus his organic metal skin is
actually called osmium it is not
indestructible it's not like adamantium
or vibranium or something along those
lines it is highly resistant to extreme
high and extremely low temperatures but
given the nature of the Sentinels the
strength that they possess in an effort
to basically take out guys like the
Incredible Hulk and people like that
sure they were able to destroy this
guy's body pretty well but that's when
Kitty Pride wakes up and ultimately it
comes to this realization nothing in the
Future Has Changed now that's where the
original Days of Future present came
into play because the belief with the
original Days of Future Past is that by
stopping the assassination in the past
everything in the future would just
cease to exist much like the movie right
if you guys remember in the movie that
Wolverine succeeded that the
assassination was stopped and everybody
just vanished right and everything just
went back as if it never it was like
that future never happened that's not
how it exists here the argument that
Marvel created here is they said okay in
order to avoid a Paradox it doesn't make
any sense logically for the X-Men to go
to the past and stop the assassination
that creates the future that they just
came from it doesn't make any sense how
do you square that Circle it's going to
leave people baffled and nonsensical so
what Marvel does is they create a branch
Universe they say in order for the
entire reason for Kitty Pride to go into
the past to even exist in the first
place that future has to exist Days of
Future Past has to exist and so what
what that meant is that by stopping the
assassination the guaranteed future of
the main Marvel universe is no longer
Days of Future Past right now it's just
whatever form that future takes based on
whatever things transpire over the
course of the main Marvel universe's
timeline Days of Future Past is now an
alternate reality it's now a what if
what if the assassination had gone
through and no one had been there to
stop it that becomes Days of Future Past
that's how that works when it comes to
Branch universe and Marvel and so
because of this they are basically now
living in an alternate reality and
because of that their effort is to find
a way to just like stop and annihilate
the entirety of the Sentinel forces
because if they don't Europe and the
rest of the world will nuke North
America and so as they go on this
Mission they end up tracking down what's
called the high Sentinel Trinity
basically these three Sentinels that
govern everything now that is also a big
difference it wasn't necessarily
established at that point in time in the
original Days of Future Past but you
ended up learning about a sentinel
called Master Mold this Sentinel that
creates other Sentinels kind of a funny
little tidbit here there was a story in
the 1990s called uh operation Zero
Tolerance where you basically ended up
coming across a guy named Bastion who
was the result of the Nimrod Sentinel
from Daisy Future Past traveling to the
present and merging with master mold in
the present day and creating a whole new
guy operation Zero Tolerance was dope
that was really good it was almost as
good as Extinction agenda right it was a
really good the '90s were a great time
to read X-Men to be honest with you guys
we need to cover like X-Men in the 9s
that's what we need to do '90s X-Men
Comics it was a great time and so what
this does is it basically leads to the
resistance force making its move the
cool thing is we have Magneto we've got
Rachel Summers in her traditional outfit
right black with the ponytail the whole
nine yards the one that she's the most
synonymous with from like her original
appearances Bishop is here of course
alongside uh Kitty pride and then we
also find out that sink and Laura Kenny
both survive and these guys race into
this conflict against the Sentinels in
order to destroy them but we don't find
out what happens because that's the end
of the story with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you need to get caught up make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later it's one crazy
Cliffhanger isn't it peace